in one week from today resorts world
will open for business
that means more and more people visiting
the north part of the strip and that has
the surrounding businesses
really excited joe mueller is live on
las vegas boulevard near convention
center with what businesses are looking
forward to
joe well despite the heat there are
workers out here getting this job done
take a look we've been watching
uh crews finish this giant monitor out
here on las vegas boulevard and they've
been testing it
for the past half an hour or so and like
you said a lot of people are excited
about this including the businesses
just across the street here they're
excited for the boom
in business as construction at resorts
world wraps up the excitement is
building
oh i'm very excited vegas nail spa owner
helen pham says they have been waiting
there's a lot of people
in here busy she expects a big boost in
business
resorts world is the first resort to be
built on the strip in over a decade
rocky patel says this could mean more
people coming into their cigar store
is this open my business is going up so
i'm very excited
for years people have watched everything
shiny and new come to the southern part
of the strip
now it's here this resource world is is
going to change the game
you know we're bringing a lot of
business to the side of the side of the
strip
edwin bolaro from lbc exotic car rental
company says this means more eyes on
their cars and
more business they'll be able to see the
cars from their hotel rooms we're just
walking down the boulevard here that
they're fixing up so
it's going to be really good we're
excited
now back out here live you're taking
another look at those workers getting
the finishing touches put on resorts
world as they are set to open
in one week's time again we were
watching them just a short time ago
test out this brand new giant monitor
our station's just around the corner and
it hasn't been on in some time
but this will open to the public next
thursday at 11 p.m
reporting on the strip joe mold 8 news
now